Die nasa will die reise von der erde zum mars über einen zwischen posten im all abwickeln dem deep space
gateway eine art umsteigebahnhof hinter dem mond der viele vorteile mit sich bringt ende der 2030er jahre
sollen die ersten menschen dann von dort zum mars gelangen jetzt der umfangreiche report zum thema in zusammenarbeit mit technology review
am ende des videos haben wir eine kostenlose ausgabe dieser wirklich sehr spannenden zeitschrift für euch exklusiv klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Erde mond mars so sieht die geplante route zum mars mit dem umweg über den mond nach den neuesten plänen der nasa aus die
vorteile des zwischen postens im all deep space
gateway die sg liegen auf der hand raumschiffe müssten beim abflug von dort keine
erdanziehung mehr überwinden und würden so auf ihrer reise zum mars weniger treibstoff verbrauchen die nasa plant die
raumstation nicht im erd- orbit sondern hinter dem mond im so genannten halo
bitte heben sich die schwer kräfte von erde und mond für einen dritten körper auf so ließe sich die raumstation relativ easy
auf dieser bahn halten ohne viel energieaufwand um gegen
gravitationskräfte
anzusteuern ein weiterer vorteil von hier aus ließen sich auch die
rückseite und die pole des mondes erforschen was bisher noch nicht wirklich passiert ist die einzelnen etappen des projektes sind schon in planung
ab 2022 sollen die benötigten module des die sg zum zielort gebracht werden und zwar an bord der neuen trägerrakete
space launch system mit an bord außerdem eine orion kapsel mit bis zu sechs astronauten
astronauten die die module zusammensetzen und konfigurieren eine weitere mission im jahr 2022
soll auch das solarkraftwerk des dsg in den halo orbit bringen
in den jahren darauf folgen dann das habitat das logistik modul und eine luftschleuse für die geplanten außeneinsätzen
läuft alles glatt wird die station schon
2025 einsatzbereit sein insgesamt sollen die drei module des deep space
gateways auf 50 tonnen gewicht kommen deutlich kleiner also als die ss die
internationale raumstation mit einer gesamtmasse von
450 tonnen und 15 modulen doch das ist kein problem denn die neue raum basis soll weder eine voll ausgestattete
forschungsstation beinhalten noch dauerhafte man sein die geplanten missionen sind mit 60 tagen angepeilt
der halo bild lässt sich mit einfachen navigation season anfliegen was auch in sachen mondforschung äußerst positiv zu bewerten ist
dazu markus landgraf von der esa dass die sg hat den vorteil dass mit ihm auch kleinere raketen
nachschub zu einer mondbasis liefern können wollte man nachschub direkt zum mond bringen müsste man einen einschuss manöver fliegen also vor dem mond
abbremsen um auf seiner umlaufbahn zu landen
angedacht sind also wieder verwendbare länder die zwischen der mondoberfläche und dem dsc pendeln aber nicht nur das das ds sie soll auch als
kommunikationsknoten benutzt werden und zwar mit einer laserbasierten
datenverbindung schon 2013 hatte die nasa die technologie getestet an leser module auf einen forschungssatelliten
tauscht und dabei daten mit der erde aus und zwar mit 600 megabit pro
sekunde heißt also ein skype gespräch zum mond sollte locker drin sein dass die es sie also als
kommunikations und verkehrskreuz für mondmissionen aber eben nicht nur das denn es soll durchaus auch als eine art
testumgebung seien für technologien die für eine mars-mission gebraucht werden die ersten marsianer sollen außerdem am dsg üben
selbstständig zu arbeiten und auch in notfällen zu handeln denn auf einer reise zum mars kann man nicht auf hilfe von der erde hoffen
die laufzeit der
kommunikationssignale von einigen minuten sind dafür einfach zu lang um eine lange reise zum mars zu ermöglichen sind zudem neue
triebwerks technologien notwendig die nasa entwickelt ein
verbessertes hall triebwerk hier werden gas zeichen elektrisch geladen und von einem magnetfeld auf rund 100000 kilometer pro stunde
beschleunigt die triebwerke des dsc sollen dann auf bis zu 15 kilowatt kommen die effekte schubkraft ist mit
1,5 minuten
super kleinen zum vergleich das triebwerk merlin 1d von spacex das in der
welt eingesetzt wird kommt auf einen schub von fast einer million juden dennoch reicht der geringe schuf völlig aus für die geplanten
manöver der dsg solarzellen sollen den benötigten strom liefern insgesamt
solarbetriebene hall triebwerke und ein chemisches triebwerk sollen dann auch
schlussendlich die raumfähre zum mars antreiben die ab
2027 am gsg geplant ist diese fähre besteht aus einem lande modul einem antriebsmodul und einem habitat bis zu
400 tage soll die raumfähre
damit bis zum mars braucht an der gravitation des mondes sollen sie schwung holen und dann mit dem horn antrieb beschleunigen die raumfähre soll bereits
2033 eine solche mission bestehen erst einmal ohne passagiere bis zu 1000 an der tage könnte dann die darauffolgende
bemannte mission dauert der aufenthalt der astronaut und astronautinnen auf dem mars ist bislang mit 300 tagen angepeilt dafür benötigt die raumfähre allerdings
einen ressourcen kreislauf für wasser und sauerstoff ein vergleichbares system testet die esa gerade im columbus modul der iss
hier wird wasser in sauer und wasserstoff
gespalten sauerstoff wird der atemluft beigemischt und der wasserstoff mit dem co2 aus der atemluft zu methan und wasser umgewandelt
das methan kann als treibstoff gespeichert werden oder aber im all entsorgt werden und in einem bioreaktor gewinnen alten aus den verbleibenden co2
sauerstoff zurück ein kreislauf der tatsächlich fast vollständig ohne zusätzlichen sauerstoff
auskommt eine weitere herausforderung für den plan der nasa ist die strahlung im all
sonneneruptionen und kosmische strahlung gefährden hinter dem mond nicht nur die bordelektronik
sondern auch die gesundheit der astronauten und astronautinnen in besonderem ausmaß wie soll man die neue raumstation und mars fairen davor schützen
sonneneruptionen so wenn es lassen sich relativ präzise vorhersagen so das equipment und versorgungsgüter sicher gelagert werden könnten und ein schutzanzug
angezogen werden könnte doch warum der umweg über den mond wenn eine bemannte mars-mission auch anders funktionieren
könnte erinnern wir uns an die pläne von ihnen musk dem gründer von spacex er will in den nächsten zwei jahren eine gigantische
rakete bauen die big felkel rocket oder auch big fucking rocket wie fa mit einer höhe von
160 metern von 2024 könnte sie nutzlasten von bis zu 150 tonnen in den niedrigen erdorbit bringen oder
100 menschen aus dem orbit zum mars allerdings auch mit zwischenstopp denn eine tankfüllung der bfa erreicht nur bis in die erdumlaufbahn
deswegen soll zunächst ein
treibstoffdepot in den r
wird gebracht werden eine bfa
oberstufe an die dann die zweite
oberstufe andocken kann und aufgetankt wird der treibstoff für den rückweg vom mars zur erde soll dann auf dem roten planeten aus co2 und wasser
hergestellt werden alle ressourcen von spacex sollen in dieses projekt gesteckt werden die kosten werden auf bis zu 430 millionen
us-dollar geschätzt vielen dank an
technology review in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion dieser hammer zeitschrift ist dieses video entstanden und exklusive klicks und zuschauer
aber ich jetzt ein geschenk ihr bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe gratis wenn er auf diesen link klickt wenn ihr kein video zu
diesen dämon zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp dafür einfach hier klicken und am besten auch meine schwester
canucks und social media abonnieren das geht hier
und dann habe ich noch ein
weiteres spannendes video da geht es nämlich mit weiter mondstation einzeln auf dem mond entdeckt da geht's hier weiter bis dann
bleibt dran